we save lives every day  strangers and there's always  enough time  but i failed to save jason from this  life  joker got a hold of stolen uranium he's  selling it to terrorists  he's gonna take batman and robin  together to close this case you take  them down while i investigate that  warehouse we track joker to  please tell the big man i said hello  i alone will become more than the dreams  and nightmares they imagined for me  the red hood's knowledge of my tactics  my history  this was getting personal  joker showed me the truth evil can't be  cured  only killed  [Music]  [Music]  because of my choice i had to avoid  repeating mistakes  you